hasn't sunk in yet no absolutely not
like it's okay girl I forgot to thanks
Oh is anybody you want to think right
now you can yes well let you do that
like when you're doing your second
speech okay what's this Aneke go ahead
my coach Ted Sabarsky who has been here
from the very very beginning from the
pilot on forward I just I saw like hurry
up and I was like wow I gotta get the
stage and I'm sure there are others that
I will remember later on tonight good we
got it out there yeah there's gotta be a
good feel you won the Emmy for this role
so you're like kind of on a little
streak here yeah I mean honestly this
down so you know but it
this job is job that I never thought I
would have I went to drama school I was
very dramatic and and I'm so grateful to
every single person who gave the
opportunity to try this thing that I
really wasn't sure that I could do and
and I've learned so much from such
extraordinary talents I mean this cast
the writers it's insane I'm feel very
very very lucky you know there's a lot
of people saying that the character
there's some Joan Rivers that's in the
character somebody based on any truth to
that is that she's not based on anyone
specifically I remember asking Amy about
that as well early on I think she's kind
of an amalgamation of a lot of different
women possibly that Amy knows herself
certainly with some influences from
comedians like Joan Rivers Phyllis
Diller I looked at women like moms
Mabley and Jean Carol Carol Burnett I
mean come on I think she's a big ol
mash-up of all of them yeah did you see
Carol tonight and tell her the data okay
I was like oh hi bad I actually gave
presented laughter and I think I just I
saw her I totally blacked out it was
crazy did you tell her some of her was
in the character no I did not I hope you
have to do that Abby see her tonight
right I hear there's some rumor that you
could have said I do any truth to that I
don't talk about my personal life I
can't give that out all right but Friday
no you did good effort
yeah well if you did you look like your
beautiful blushing bride if you did but
if not then you know someday correct an
adventure right but congratulations on
this thank you very much awesome this is
beautiful bling to have right yeah
you're cute yeah I know
let's have a good time tonight whoop it
up a little bit you're gonna whoop it up
a little demo definitely okay
[Music]